hey folks and welcome to another episode
of good news gaming the show that takes
all the fun and good stuff from the
weekend games just like this beat save a
moment that went very very wrong in the
good news this week some Halo fans
finally landed a trick jump that they've
been working on for 10 years in the
final mission in Halo Reach there is a
Master Chief statue Easter egg that lies
just out-of-bounds and for the last 10
years a group called tamesha strike Oct
have been determined how have you
pronounce the name
they've been determined to stand on top
of that statue which you know seems easy
except in the final mission in Halo
Reach you have like one life no
checkpoint and you're constantly being
attacked by enemies because the whole
point of that mission is you're supposed
to die anyway it took them 10 years and
they finally did it and it's an
incredible achievement in the video to
celebrate it is also very well made to
go have a look I really need to put a
moratorium on the amount of times I'm
gonna say incredible in this episode but
honestly this next story is absolutely
incredible
so there was a guy who stag do a
bachelor party depending on way watching
this from was cancelled because of Cove
in nineteen so his friends got together
and built him a real life controllable
RPG but in like the real world so that
he could get his own back and take
revenge on Cove it this is honestly
absolutely incredible there is a remote
control car a GoPro feeds multiple zoom
cools friends acting like NPCs there are
random battles and of course the
currency in this game isn't gold it's a
toilet rolls watch the whole video it's
linked below this guy has the best
friends ever when I was doing the show I
didn't expect to be covering like plug
in release
but honestly I watched this video today
and I was so impressed with it I knew I
had to include it nvidia has released a
new plug-in called r-tx voice that
massively improves my quality I work
from home
we all are mostly working from home
these days as I'm shooting videos I
don't know if you can hear there are
currently sirens going on so I
definitely need to use this but
basically it just takes your mic and
gets rid of all the terrible stuff in
the background and sounds incredible
this video of a guy like he has a fan
he's hammering the desk and you can't
hear that at all this is gonna change so
many people's lives people who like
twitch stream or film videos from home
it's super cool all right there I just
disabled the filter this is what it
sounds like right now hey guys welcome
to afternoon coffee does this sound cool
is this good audio quality let me enable
the r-tx filter again hold on here are
our TX coming on and now we are okay
still I still hear the same thing
through my headset it's super I got ear
bone my neighbor's can probably hear
this deadblow hammer this is just a
quick shout it's the lovely folks at
insect queen clothing back in the UK
they make gaming branded clothes like
t-shirts hoodies hats pins etc but
they've also just donated 10,000
high-grade masks to the NHS back in the
UK which is a super cool donation and
you guys are fast I love hearing about
gaming content Easter eggs I love
listening to developers talk and kind of
like Dell through the things that they
make which is why this next story really
tickled me because it's something that
was cut from fable Ted Timmons who used
to work at lion head revealed that when
fable The Lost Chapters was in
development there was a very specific
flatulence related gameplay mechanic I
think you can call it that had to be cut
and I'll let him tell the story cuz it's
really good and it was crazy right
because you could
[Music]
talk to your thread friend while playing
fable through messenger and then you
could do forward slash fast to your
friend playing the game and the game
would then firing at me on their screen
so like let's be nice
super Lionhead super fable no other game
company in the world is gonna do that
for better or for worse I should
probably say you might not know this
about me but I absolutely adore
Dishonored I should have actually put
that on the TV instead of overwatch to
really hammer home that point but it's
always installed on my playstation just
ready to go whenever I need it it's like
my comfort game and I love watching
people play it especially people who are
really really good at it
cuz I'm okay at it played it a lot but
I'm still very very cautious stealth
gamer beer is an absolute beast at
dishonored and the latest Dishonored 2
stealth hi chaos video is genuinely
astounding and like my mouth was open
behalf of it if you have any interest in
watching super super high skill gameplay
please watch it I bet you all thought I
was done with Animal Crossing well no
because I'm still playing it and people
still out there making incredible things
in it the big meme this week is people
taking famous album covers and then
making a cake a slider version of it
here are some of my favorites in no
particular order but there's rumors by
Fleetwood Mac nevermind my nirvana
revolver by the Beatles and heroes by
David Bowie it's so good but I think my
absolute absolute favorite has to be
Caravan Mountain can I borrow a feeling
it's the crossover I never knew I needed
people making such cool things in Animal
Crossing still we had the mother remake
we had Pokemon and now someone's made a
like as a full Zelda dungeon in the game
people are making such cool things and I
don't even have the island terraforming
app yet but I mean its nature day coming
up there's a whole load of new stuff in
the game so I'll be spending a lot of
time in there so maybe one day I'll get
to make my masterpiece if you've made
anything cool in Animal Crossing make
sure to let me know or if you have any
other new stories you want to see
featured on the show
check them in the comments below or i'm
on twitter at lucy jokes games my dams
are open and if you want to join the
games for discord which you definitely
show
because it's a lot of fun shoot me a
message on there and I'll get you in
alright that's it for this week hope you
staying safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]